>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Hello. Welcome.
My name is Kate Julian
and I'm the deputy editor
of the Sunday Outlook section
at the Washington Post.
The Post is a very
proud charter sponsor
of the festival again this year.
Before we get started
I want to remind you
that the pavilions presentations
are being filmed for the Library
of Congress' website
and for their archives.
Please be mindful of this as
you enjoy the presentation.
In addition please do not sit on
the camera risers that are located
in the back of the pavilion.
Thanks. It's my great pleasure
to be introducing National Book
award winner M.T. Anderson.
M.T. Anderson was born and
grew up in Stow, Massachusetts
but he spent a couple of years
as a young child in Italy
where he was fascinated by the roman
ruins he saw dotting the landscape.
When he returned to kindergarten
in the United States his teacher
was confused by his style of playing
with blocks, which involved stacking
blocks in big jumbled piles.
As he patiently explained to
her, he was building ruins.
He says that's what he's
been doing ever since.
[Laughter] If Anderson's
writings are ruins,
they are magnificent ones.
He has published everything from
picture books to children's novels
to books for young adults.
Excuse me.
His short stories for
adults have been published
in such literary journals
as Northwest Review,
the Colorado Review
and Conjunctions.
He also moves seemingly
effortlessly from genre to genre
from vampire novels to
biographies of classical composers,
from science fiction to satire.
Whatever he is writing he combines a
focus on big ideas with a sharp ear
for dialog and a wicked
sense of humor.
As he has said, "I
love being an author.
There is nothing like realizing
that all one has to for the rest
of the day is sit around
making up jokes
that will entertain
me and a 10 year old."
[Laughter] His satirical 2002
young adult novel Feed Imagines not
so improbably a future in which may
people have a device called a feed
implanted in their brains
thereby enabling a kind
of wireless instant message.
Feed was a finalist for
the National Book Award
and the New York Times
heralded it as proof
that young adult novels are alive
and well and able to deliver a jolt.
And then there is Octavian
Nothing the first volume
of which won the National
Book Award.
A profile of Anderson
in the Washington Post two years
ago described Octavian Nothing as,
"An ultra-challenging
two-volume young adult novel
that runs 900 plus pages
and asks teen readers
to contemplate the
American Revolution
from a wildly unfamiliar
point of view."
I should add that it's written
in 18th century English.
Anderson's books expect a lot of
their readers there is no doubt
but as he remarked in the same Post
profile, "It's insulting to believe
that teens should have a different
kind of book than an adult should."
His most recent book, The Suburb
beyond the Stars is a sequel
to 2004's The Game of Sunken Stars.
Please join me in welcoming
M.T. Anderson.
[Applause]
>> M.T. Anderson: Thank you.
It's great to see you all here.
It's wonderful especially
given this heat.
You know I come from the wilds of
Vermont at this point and you know
up there it's sort of 45 degrees.
To come down here and
have a few extra days
of summer is both a
blessing and curse,
but with this jacket
on mainly a curse.
Anyway thank you for coming out.
Today what I'm going to talk
about is writing and travel
and leaving home and returning
home and specifically the suburbs
and The Suburb beyond the Stars.
And I should begin to say --
by saying that I grew up in
a small town in Massachusetts
and it was a very standard town.
You know we had our little
brick library with a turret sort
of from the Carnegie era.
We had our little you know white
churches with the steeples.
We had our haunted house and you
know our apple orchard our bad girl,
sort of all these things in
a standard American town.
And it was noted only to be
intensely normal and dull
in America, which was
in fact how I liked it.
And we were all proud of that.
Even the bullies in my town
were perfect American bullies.
Like they stuck with the
classics you now what I mean?
Like the swishy, the
swirley, the monkey bite.
You know all the things that
really you know have continued
through the generations
to torment nerds like me.
So you know perhaps
because my town was in fact
so resolutely American I
very early took an interest
in the idea of traveling.
When I went to that little red
brick library I read a lot of books
that were about travel to the
most exotic places possible.
So I loved all those books like --
you know those old books
of adventure from the turn
of the century where sort
of English people wearing
in fact far heavier jackets than
the one I'm wearing now traipse
through the desert or go
up through the Himalayas
and then are standing there next
to this sort of treasure trove
of you know ancient
Tibetan artifacts
that they have just arrested
out of the hands of the monks
or whatever it is that
they're going to take back
to England and put in a museum.
I loved all of those sort of insane
books heading off into the wild.
And of course all those books of
travel that are entirely fantastical
like Conan the Barbarian.
I don't know if anyone actually
still reads Conan the Barbarian.
But you now he travels
around the early earth
as it is depicted despite the fact
that Conan the Barbarian's
author lived in Texas and claimed
that the whole thing was supposed
to be somehow a portrait of Texas
that just happened to include
yeah, giant, brawny barbarians,
giant snake gods, demons, you know.
Although maybe actually -- I
haven't been to Texas so maybe some
of you are from there I don't know.
[Laughter] So what
thrilled me in all
of these books are not just the
specific moments of adventure.
You know the fumbling mummies,
the lassoed pterodactyls
but also the vast untamed landscape.
In my little safe, suburban
house I dreamed of a world
of howling wilderness
and secret valleys.
I hoped that there were
still places to discover --
places like that to discover on
the earth and I hoped even more
that there were still places
that remained undiscovered
and unplundered until
the end of time.
And part of the pleasure of
these books was not just the plot
but the mood of place.
The sense of this expansive
landscape of adventure,
that's what I loved, the
romance of geography itself.
So I always assumed that when I
grew older I would be traveling
around the world and writing
books of exotic adventure.
As it turned out however there
were two little problems with that.
So problem number one is
that it appears that people
in other countries speak
different languages.
[Laughter] It's very irritating
for those of us who speak English.
And we are trying to rectify
it in all kinds of ways
but we still haven't ironed it out
and I'm horrible at
languages myself.
So when I travel it's
a real problem.
I mean I can think a very basic
German so in a pinch if I need
to order like a bombing raid on
the Netherlands or something,
but basically I -- you know
I'm really bad at languages
and I've been trying for about
20 years to learn French.
But unfortunately it's,
I don't know, no dice.
Pada dice.
Something always goes wrong.
In fact one summer
a girlfriend of mine
and I decided we would
both learn French.
And she learned all these mamby
pamby sentences like you know,
"Which way to the bus station" and
"How much for a pitcher of milk?"
Well I decided I was going
to learn French entirely
from French baroque opera.
[Laughter] Which for one thing means
I actually don't know any French
at all.
But also it means that
the conversation has
to reach a certain kind of pitch
before I can join in [Laughter]
because all the phrases
I know are things like,
"I fear his terrible vengeance."
And "Fatal love.
Drink this scorpions venom
and be forever silenced."
Yeah sure, I can say that
in French if you need me to.
"It is your own children's
bodies I hurl before you."
That I can say.
You know I'm right there if that's
where the conversation goes.
[Laughter] But, yeah it never
really works out for me.
You know we learned French
to go to France and it turned
out we bought the tickets.
We didn't get them in the mail
though and we ordered them,
this is before the internet.
And we didn't get them in the mail
and we finally went to the office
and it turned out there was an empty
office with a guy like the AT&T guy
like closing off the
two phone lines.
And the owners of this travel agency
had actually fled to the middle east
with our money and everyone else's.
So we didn't go to France.
We went to Canada instead which
is America's France I guess.
Well any we went to Quebec, Quebec
City and that kind of thing.
We were traveling around on the
Gas Bay Peninsula, which is a very,
very beautiful area up there
where in fact most people
do not speak English.
They do only speak French.
And this was a good example
of how terrible my French is.
So we're up there wandering
through this beautiful,
beautiful provincial park up
there and we came to this place
where all the grass was crushed down
and clearly several large deer
had been sleeping there overnight.
It was really kind
of an idyllic scene
and we're walking along the path
away from there and this guy comes
up and asks me in French,
"What's up the path."
So I think, well I'm going to
try and tell him in French.
So what I wanted to say to him
was, "Over there there's a spot
where some large deer
were sleeping."
So now of course I couldn't
remember the word for deer.
I remembered only that it was
cognate with the Latin word
for deer, which is cervus.
The word I was actually
looking for is cerf.
I was thinking that
the word must be cervo.
Well anyone who knows French knows
that the word cervo
means not deer but brain.
So what I said to him in the end
was not "Over there there's a spot
where some large deer were
sleeping" but "That is the place
where the giant brain sleeps."
[Laughter] So he looked at me
in incomprehension and disgust.
I realized that, "Damn, I had once
again failed to learn French."
So I just said to him, "It is your
own children whose bodies I hurl
before you."
And I stomped off into the forest.
So he wandered off thinking
[Speaking in a foreign language]
until he went around the corner
and found himself face to face
with the giant tentacles
and massive single eye
of the disembodied brain,
waked from it's slumber.
So that happens to me every time
I try to speak a foreign language.
Like why did I have to discover
that in Napoli the word [Speaking
in a foreign language]
means bring me some chicken.
The word [Speaking in a foreign
language] means bring me some
dog meat.
Why do they have to be so close?
And this brings to my second
point, the reason I found it hard
to travel as much as I wanted to.
I am drab and fussy eater.
I have a lot of good allergies, I'm
hypoglycemic and that means I need
to eat a huge amount of protein
to actually keep myself running
and that's a huge problem
when you're traveling.
I mean it really does not take
me much to make me hungry.
If I were the Donner party I
would have actually suggested
that we started eating the
people before we even set
out from Illinois.
So one time I was in this
little ex kingdom of Sikkim
which is up in the Himalayans.
And I had cleverly
chosen to go there
when the Avian bird flu
was raging which meant
that there was actually an
interdiction on all chicken --
on the serving of chicken
and all other animals there.
Now never mind that you can't
actually catch Avian bird flu
from cooked chicken and never mind
the live chickens are walking right
through the level of restaurants
with their little brood
of chicks following right behind
them in a row, proudly heading
to table seven if having a
family night out you know.
It's the 12 top or
whatever with the chickens
but anyway there was
no chicken to be had.
I was in this town which was
called perhaps fittingly Yuksom,
which was on the edge of the
howling Himalayan wilderness
that contains Kangchenjunga.
So I went to this restaurant
and the guy said,
"Oh we have one frozen chicken
from before the interdiction.
You can have that.
Would you like that?
And I was like, "Yeah,
I would like that.
I would like that."
Because you know I'm
falling apart with protein.
So I beg for this chicken
and he says,
"I'll bring you chicken pieces."
And I said, "Yeah, chicken
pieces, yeah, yeah, yeah."
So he goes and I wait and I
wait and I wait and I wait
and finally he brings
it out and it's not
like chicken pulled off
the bone like in a curry
and it's not chicken pieces like
thighs or drumsticks and breasts.
What he'd done is he'd taken this
precious chicken, the last chicken
in Sikkim and he diced it.
He cubed it precisely and every
morsel was like a little cube
of like bone and tendon
and meat all in --
with sort of a few scraps of skin
with covered with chili powder.
But you know like who
cared, I was desperate.
I picked it up and began to
gnaw on the bones like this.
So I'm gnawing on the chicken
trying to tear the meat off
and meanwhile there are these
stray cats on the dining room table
that are walking towards me
trying to get the chicken.
And these are mangy stray cats
with big bald patches
and bumps all over them.
They're slinking along towards me.
I'm sitting there trying
to keep them away
with my elbow while eating these
things and then they're hair starts
to fly all over the place.
It's getting caught
in the chili powder.
I'm eating their hair,
pushing them backwards
and then one grabs
a piece of chicken.
And the thing is that cats can
choke on cooked chicken bones.
It's very dangerous and even
though they were strays I couldn't
have that.
So I'm taking the chicken
out of the cats mouth then
with my same hand shoving
it in my mouth
and I just thought there's no
way I'm coming out of his alive
without some insane feline
disease which is going
to be very hard to
explain to my doctor.
So it was at his moment that
I decided that there has go
to be a better way to do this.
There has got to be a way to travel
the world, experience the thrill
of travel some place where I can
still Chipwiches and Captain Crunch.
[Laughter] So I decided I would
focus on novels of adventure,
exotic adventure which
would allow me then
to experience these
fantastical vistas
in the safety of my own living room.
I would travel in my mind.
Explore new realms
from my office chair.
Emily Dickenson says,
"There is no frigate
like a book to take us lands away."
So I could remain chained to home
and hearth and still arrange widely.
I could stay in my own home and
still dream of traveling in places
like Vermont and Delaware.
So that is in fact what my
recent books have been about.
And I should say that the idea
of literary traveling is beautifully
summed up by T.S. Elliot.
He writes this in this
poem, Little Gidding.
"We shall not cease
from exploration.
In the end of all our exploring
will to arrive where we started
and know the place
for the first time."
And I love that idea that writing
takes you away from a place you know
so that when you come back to
what you know it's unfamiliar.
So in the case of this book
that I'm hocking today,
which I'm sure is available
at a nearby bookseller,
The Suburb Beyond the Stars,
the idea was the first book
in that series -- it's the
second book of that series
that will contain four books in all,
the first one is actually
called The Suburb --
I'm sorry the first one is
called The Game of Sunken Places
and it was written about
kind of magical events
that take place in Vermont.
Because when I was a kid that's
where we would vacation in Vermont
and vacationing there, reading
adventure books while I was there,
somehow that amazing
Vermont landscape
with all those beautiful
mountains it looked so mysterious.
It looks like you could
get lost forever
and no one would ever
be able to find you.
That in my mind became
like grafted on to all
of the adventures I was
reading while I was there.
So I thought what I could
do is I will write a series
of adventure books that
take place in this sort
of transformed magical Vermont.
So The Game of Sunken Places
was the first one of those.
The second one which has just come
out is called the Suburb Beyond
the Stars and it's a continuation.
It's a kind of a sort of
horror novel set in a suburb,
because I grew up in a suburb.
I know the suburbs well.
In some ways I thought
to myself it's not scary
to have a horror novel.
I mean its light horror but
it's not scary to have that set
in a Victorian house because
that doesn't do the thing
that T. S. Eliot is
talking about in a way.
A Victorian house no longer takes
you away from yourself in a sense
because very few of us live
in Victorian houses you know.
And we're prepared when we see a
Victorian novel in a house we think,
"Oh when are the chains
going to start clinking.
When is the headless
nun going to come by?"
If she doesn't come out we like
yell down the hall for her,
"Headless nun", you know?
Incidentally, this isn't entirely
relevant to my talk but like ghosts
that appear at the exact time
when they're murdered to they have
to like readjust for
daylight savings time?
[Laughter] Just a question
do you know what I mean
or they late for half the year?
I don't know.
Anyway so I thought to myself if
I do this novel set in a suburb
which is a place I know, it
will actually feel stranger
because the unknown, the mysterious,
the supernatural will
be taking place
in a setting that is very familiar.
It will defamiliarize
the familiar and I think
that will be a more powerful effect.
So this book is in fact set in
a suburb very much like the ones
that were being built around me
when I was a kid except I've update
the architecture a little bit
to make it you know the
architecture of the 2000's
as opposed to the 1980's.
So they are more like palladium
windows for those of you
who are connoisseurs of the
architecture of the suburbs.
And in fact, the other
book that I have come
out with recently is called Jasper
Dash and the Flame Bits of Delaware
which was a transformation
of the state of Delaware
into something even more
exciting than it already is.
And so if you look at my website
which is mtanderson.com
you can find actually --
I have like an interactive
map of the state of Delaware
as a fantasy map that will tell
you completely untrue facts
about the state.
Though I found I visited it
just the other day and I have
to say nothing could be weirder
than the actual experience
of going there.
I met the governor who had
written me a very tart letter
about a few inaccuracies in my book.
So it's the only time a state
governor has actually called
me Buster.
[Laughter] But anyway -- that letter
is actually reproduced in the back
of the paperback version
of this book Jasper Dash
the Flame Bits of Delaware.
So I went to meet him.
He was tremendously nice.
He was a very good sport and
I'm driving back from Delaware
and many call it the capital
of Delaware and on Route 1
and we're driving back late at
night and we see a helicopter going
over with a big search
light and we said,
"Oh someone must have
escaped from somewhere."
Well just today when I
was at the Delaware table,
the different state's booths
they told me that what was going
on was sniper was actually
firing on the cars on the highway
that I was driving on and they
were trying to find the sniper.
So there was my Delaware experience
so actually it was
far more frightening
than the Delaware I had imagined.
[Laughter] Do you know what
I mean, but that's unusual.
So yeah these books in
a way are all my attempt
to reimagine the American
landscape in a fantastical way,
in a way that is kids
like so many of us do.
We you know -- so many of us
see the little stream that runs
through the backyard of our house
as a mighty river or the hill nearby
as a mountain and make
up a kind of mythology
of the imagination
about the place we live.
I wanted to make up
that kind of mythology.
So you now when I think of
the fantasy books I loved,
Robert E. Howard, the creator
of Conan the Barbarian he based
Conan's home Semaria on his realm
of keltic twighlight
on Fredericksburg.
Little did he know the
actor slated to play Conan,
the king of Aquilonia
would instead end
up playing governor of California.
[Laughter] In H.P.
Lovecraft's Dream Quest
of Unknown Kadath a many journeys
through a landscape of nightmare
in search of a city of dreams only
to discover what he really seeks
is an image of Beacon Hill,
Boston from his childhood
glimmering in the sunset.
Ray Bradbury's Martian
Chronicles maybe set in the deserts
and the canals and broken
cities of the red planet,
but what the tales record
in many ways is the tale
of American settlement.
In a similar way I wonder whether
we Americans embrace the landscape
of fantasy so that we can
once again be pioneers.
We can once again be faced with
vast wilderness, this time purged
for the guilt of its plunder.
We drive through our own landscapes
and see towns merge sloppily
with other towns, no seam, no
distinction, no woodland at the edge
of the village in which
an ogre might lurk
and we past the same rotation
of Home Depot, WalMart, T.G.I.
Friday's and Ruby Tuesday's
and we long for a map
where one town is made of brass
and another of fluted pillars.
In that land the forests
are huge again.
The mountains are full of mystery.
We may continue to expand and these
kingdoms will never be exhausted
of their riches.
Our opacity need never be satisfied.
Though we've sloshed already
from shore to shining shore,
we seek now this soothing manifest
destiny of dreams and we light
for new territories unexplored.
Thank you.
[Applause] Thank you.
Now we have time for
questions if anyone has them
or we can all just sit here really
awkwardly for about 10 minutes.
Oh and there are microphones.
So this gentleman right
here, driven to read.
>> Yes I was wondering, although
you didn't talk about it,
I was wondering what inspired
you for Whales on Stilts?
>> M.T. Anderson: And so he's
asking about my book Whales
on Stilts and what inspired me.
And that was book for one thing
because I was writing a historical
novel set in the revolution
which was very dark and
very hard to do for me.
And it involved a huge amount of
research so I wanted to go on kind
of a mental vacation and
whales on stilts was just kind
of me saying I want to have a
book that's purely joyful and fun
and the reader who reads
it will feel like they're
on summer vacation mentally.
And so that really was
kind of the basic idea.
I knew the characters I wanted
to have and I just had to think
of kind of struggle for them.
And around that time a very tragic
thing happened which is a bunch
of whales somehow swam
on to the beach
on Cape Cod somewhat
near where I live.
Though that was tragic I started
to think what would an invasion
of whales who want to take
back the land be like.
I mean whales actually
did walk for a while.
They got tired of it.
[Laughter] Anyway that book is
actually about this invasion
of whales that storm on to the land
with laser beam eyes
to take it back.
There you go.
Thank you for reading it.
>> Thank you for telling me why.
>> M.T. Anderson: Yeah.
Hi.
>> Keeping with your points on
foreign language it feels like a lot
of your characters say in
Feed or Octavian Nothing,
speak in a language that could be
foreign to the unassuming reader.
And I've heard that you really
immerse yourself in order
to get the language choice
right and everything.
Could you talk about
that a little more?
>> M.T. Anderson: Yeah, sure.
I do a lot of like emerging
because I feel like the language
that we speak in actually
in some ways creates the
world that we live in.
You know it creates the way that we
understand it and in many creates --
it convinces us of what matters
and what doesn't matter,
that kind of thing.
So I do do a huge amount of research
about the language
before I write a book.
So for those Octavian Nothing
books set in the 18th century
for six years while I
did the research for that
and wrote them I basically read
only books from that period or about
that period like Latin and
Greek books that kind of thing.
And that's because I wanted
to get that language right.
For Feed which is a book set
in sort of an idiotic future
where everyone is a moron and as
result of having this little chip
in their head that kind of
constantly broadcasts the internet
to them, which means they
constantly are receiving you know
advertisements for everything that
they see and that kind of thing.
I read a lot of slick magazines
like you know 17 and you know GQ,
Vogue and all that kind of
thing so I had that kind
of saying like, "Hey guys."
And a voice inside my
head when I wrote that.
And one time I got a message on
some kind of blog or something.
Someone wrote, "He always uses
the word like in his writing
and no teenager says like anymore.
It's like he was a teenager back
in like the 80's or something."
[Laughter] And I said [Sound
effects] So I decided to find out
and I went down to the main
kind of student strip in Boston
and I just kind of walked
randomly down the street to see --
just sort of listening
to conversations,
but just sort of hearing
the words that were used.
And surprising the police didn't
pick me up and I discovered
after having wondered up and
down the street a few times
that overwhelmingly
people said like.
They said it so much that in fact
I felt worried about using the word
like in the normal context
by the end of the evening.
So yeah, that kind of research
is stuff that I have done.
Yeah. Back on this side sir?
>> What gave you the
idea for Jasper Dash?
>> M.T. Anderson: So
this is a question
about Jasper Dash who's a character
from my pals and perils series
that includes both Whales
on Stilts and Jasper Dash
and the Flame Pits of Delaware.
And he is a kid who is from a
kind of early adventure book
like Tom Swift or something
and he believes in sort
of exciting inventions
and he is going to sort
of you know make the world a safer
democracy and that kind of thing.
The problem is his inventions
are all like the inventions
from an old adventure book.
So he's like, "I have invented a
phone for which you need no wires.
And it's small enough you can carry
it around with you on this cart.
"And you now the problem
with that is
of course the world has really
moved past the future of the past.
And I just loved whose
books when I was a kid.
I loved the idea of reading
children's adventure books
which people hadn't read for
years and feeling like, "Wow,
my dad might have read this."
So that was kind of the idea for
that kind of reading those old books
and wanting to revive that
character and think what would it be
like for him to be
in the modern world?
But thank you for reading and
for asking the question, yeah.
Yes.
>> I love writing science
fiction books.
>> M.T. Anderson: Great.
You love writing them?
>> Well I mean like in class for --
>> M.T. Anderson: Yeah great.
>> The teachers always tell me
that you can't write anything
that you don't know with experience.
Like I told them what
about Lord of Rings,
we don't have experience on that.
>> M.T. Anderson: Yeah
exactly, yeah.
>> Would you have any
thoughts on that?
>> M.T. Anderson: Yeah
I mean I don't know
if J.R. Tolkin had hairy feet or not
but no I mean I think [Laughter]
well here's how I would put it.
You might be writing about
something you know but in a very,
very unfamiliar alien context.
So, for example a lot of people have
argued that Lord of the Rings is
in some ways about you know
the World War I for example
and the sense of loss during that.
And when you are thinking about
science fiction the things
that move you might in fact
be very familiar to you even
if they are happened
on worlds far away.
It's the internal truth,
not the external truth
that you have to really know.
And I think that's
about the time we have.
So thank you all very much.
[Applause] Thanks.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at www.loc.gov.